media mogul tyler perry made headlines
recently
when he announced that his studio would
resume production
he's got a 30-page plan for keeping the
cast and crews safe from the coronavirus
now it is among the first studios in the
country to reopen
after the entire industry came to a halt
amid this pandemic
so first on cbs this morning he let us
go behind the scenes
to take a look at the sprawling
sprawling is the word tyler perry
studios in atlanta
to see how safety is being made a
priority on his set
delta and echo
tyler perry has very ambitious plans to
film the new seasons
on his four tv shows all while keeping
the 360 people on his production team
safe from coronavirus he's calling it
camp quarantine let's go get this
all right all cast and crew are required
to live on site for each two week
production
and to limit exposure perry is flying in
actors from la
and new york on private flights wearing
a mask and social distancing are
strictly
everybody's social distancing hand
sanitizing six feet
and medical staff test everyone every
three to four days
the media mogul even constructed new
buildings on his atlanta lot
to provide housing on site with perks
like food trucks and movie nights to
keep spirits high
[Music]
all the work and planning paid off this
is our second round of testing
no positives
perry wrapped his production ahead of
schedule with cast and crew
walking off his lot testing negative for
covid19
and he plans on doing it all over again
when the next production team arrives
the camp quarantined
tyler perry joins us now from atlanta
good morning to you tyler perry
impressive with a capital i i say wow
wow wow good morning i'm sitting here mr
perry i have the
the confidential 30-page document of
camp quarantine
listen you covered all the bases you
covered you dotted every eye and crossed
every t
so i'm wondering what did you do to
prepare for this tyler
who did you talk to how did you pull
this off
well after sitting around learning
everything i could i called uh dr carlos
del rio
emory hospital dr sanjay gupta dr
colleen kraft
and we we i showed him my plan we all
worked uh very closely on it to make
sure that everybody was safe and to
to know that we've got through the first
production of sisters uh
safely it means it all worked well so
i'm really really grateful and thankful
for that because
i got to tell you gail i i being in the
position i mean i had the option to go
away and just sit and wait for a vaccine
but i had 360 employees or so on these
shows who
have bought houses and cars and and and
are taking care of their families and
who needed to work so
i had to do something i couldn't wait
around for a plan i had to do something
i know but that's what i wanted to know
because the union said listen we're
going to be issuing guidelines very soon
you could have waited for that but you
said you wanted to take extreme measures
why yeah yeah and i and i did wait for
the union all the union guidelines so we
got all of their guidelines we got the
state guidelines the city guidelines and
then
we i i went past everything that they uh
were asking for one reason and one
reason only is uh
realizing that black and brown people
are the people who are are dying the
most from covet i knew that i had to go
far far beyond and also having a crew
member at the beginning of
covet coming into america who died who
was working on another show
i mean we all knew we knew him and knew
him well so
i had to go beyond and with me living
right there with them side by side i
wanted to make sure that everybody was
safe
and so how does the testing work tyler
they come and seems like they get tested
on a regular basis
walk us through how it works yeah yeah
yeah we're tests well during
pre-production we were testing every
four days
and pre-production is when uh the crew
was actually going home into their
houses and coming in to work and so on
and so forth but
uh when we went into quarantine that
meant everybody all 300 is actually 360
people
we were all locked down here at the
campus testing every four days
and it was sanjay gupta who said because
what i was going to do is just just test
once a week but sanjay said every four
days is better because dr gupta rather
because of the incubation period and and
that has been pretty accurate
in for what we found is four to five
days of incubation
during pre-production but we had no
positives during the time that we were
actually in the quarantine
wow are you finding are people finding
it hard to follow the rules
are you getting any pushback from your
team doesn't seem like it
let me no let me just tell you this crew
i've got the best crew in the business
i've got a group of underdogs we're all
underdogs we've all been counted out
i've got former prisoners that are
working for me and these
my crew men these people came in here
with such vigor and
and tenacity and wanted to make this
work i'm so proud of them and how they
behaved and what they did
i mean it's kind of hard policing 360
people
especially at an adult summer camp when
you're trying to keep them all
from coping with an open bar and every
evening so
but but just their behavior i'm so proud
of them it almost brings me to tears
when i think about their behavior
they're good because i know i marvel at
it too tyler yeah i marvel at it too
you've just wrapped up
the second season of sisters you're
about to start on the oval i can't wait
to see what's going to happen in the
oval
it's a different kind of white house let
me tell you so what will happen
in this in this transition period what
will you do now
yeah what would you do now well right
now well right now we've got all
our sisters cast left a few days ago we
got them all back uh home safely
and now we're bringing in the overcast
so they will come in on this
coming thursday they will test and wait
uh so here's how we do we break it up
160 people check in
on thursday and then 200 people of the
crew check in on that following monday
so we get the test results of the 160
they stay in their rooms until their
results come back
then the 200 come in they stay in their
rooms until the results come back
and on the first day when we were doing
that where everybody checks in
stays in their room until the testing
come back we had two positives that were
in the camp
before we started so we were able to get
them help and get them out of the camp
so that we can maintain
the the bubble
you make it sound so easy tyler have you
had any challenges
listen every bit of it has been
challenging every bit of it's been
extremely
expensive and i got to just say thank
you to bob baker cbs vicom i know this
is cbs but i just
and scott mills at bt had had because
this was
incredibly expensive and they put up a
large
sum of the money to make this happen and
i covered the rest of which was above
and beyond
but yeah this was the most stressful
thing i've ever done because this is
these are people's lives and health
right so i'm trying to make sure that
they can
not only thrive and survive in their in
their livelihood but also
keep them safe so that has been
extremely stressful but
but i i again i could have just sat out
and waited it out but what would they
have done
i had to i had to push through yeah i
had to find a way
it's a it's typical of you tyler's
thinking of others and
you're going to hate this part but i'm
going to do it anyway because in the
last three months
you never toot your own horn i'm going
to do it for you the last three months i
just want to talk about your good deeds
paid for groceries for shoppers at 29
winn-dixie stores
provided plain service for members of
george floyd's family
paid for the funeral expenses of richard
brooks this is in the last three months
paid for tuition of a college student
who was working as a sanitation worker
in maryland
to go to harvard for his first year law
school then earlier this month
you paid for gift cards at kroger and
then you asked the atlanta police
department to help you distribute them
so we have a senior producer here that
said please
john tower is his aim please ask tyler
when he's going to come up with the
coronavirus vaccine
i mean that's what people think of when
they think about each other always going
above and beyond
i thought that was pretty good i thought
that was pretty good but where does this
helping gene come from because you are
consistent with it
and you always keep it you're not you're
never touting your own horn and i think
people should know
about what you do where does this come
from
you know this is all my mother my mother
i'd wake up in the house on on the
weekend there'd be strangers living in
the house i mean she would
if anybody was in trouble she would help
them out and and i and i know that i get
that from her and she taught me a great
deal about
compassion and helping other people and
just understanding that just because
someone is down
or having a hard time doesn't make them
less than so
it's anytime i get an opportunity to
help or to inspire because that's what
this
this is about so when it's mentioned i
do get a little uncomfortable with it
but the truth is
i wanted to inspire other people to do
some of the same things so
the inspiration of it is what's
important so i'm hoping that it inspires
more good
we've got enough hate we've got enough
division we've got enough anger we've
got enough all of that stuff
can we just bring some balance of good
and kindness and love to each other
that's what i'm looking for more of
well tyler perry mission accomplished we
thank you so much for oh tyler
it's been widely reported that megan and
harry are living at your place in los
angeles can you tell us how they're
doing
you speak english i'm sorry i think i
just lost i just lost you i just lost
you gail i'm sorry we have a bad really
bad connection
i'm sorry i think we lost gayle king
guys we lost her
thank you thank you okay great interview
thanks perry
we lost you bye tyler thank you so much